[Música]
el papá francisco pide el fin de la
violencia y la intolerancia en su visita
histórica a irak
francisco también pidió que nadie sea
considerado ciudadano de segunda clase
sobre todo los cristianos y también los
yazidíes minoría que fue perseguida por
el estado islámico tenemos reportes de
bagdad
el director de la organización mundial
de la salud pedrosa non webber y jesús
criticó la respuesta del gobierno de
brasil a la pandemia de kobe 19 y
calificó la situación de muy preocupante
durante las últimas semanas la situación
en el país sudamericano se ha
deteriorado al punto de registrar nuevos
récord de muertes diarias
el ex bailarín principal de la ópera de
parís y estrella de la danza patrick
dupont murió a la edad de 61 años de una
enfermedad devastadora según informó las
personas cercanas a su círculo dupont
fue coronado a los 21 años estrella de
la ópera de la que fue durante mucho
protagonista
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 cierra blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos a este informativo en irak
porque entre fuertes medidas de
seguridad y con mascarilla debido al
coronavirus el papá francisco de 84 años
viajó como un peregrino de la paz para
reconfortar a una de las más antiguas
comunidades cristianas del mundo el
pontífice hizo un llamado a poner fin a
la violencia en irak el extremismo y la
intolerancia además criticó los
intereses de facciones y extranjeros que
han desestabilizado al país y la región
según él en su discurso aseguró que irak
ha sufrido los efectos desastrosos de
las guerras el flagelo del terrorismo y
los conflictos sectarios a menudo
basados en un fundamentalismo incapaz de
aceptar la coexistencia pacífica de
intereses de diferentes grupos étnicos y
religiosos desde bagdad nuestra enviada
especial catalina como es ángel con
todos los detalles
desde la llegada hoy a bagdad del papá
francisco dejó claro que este será un
viaje cargado de simbolismos de webber
después de haber pasado la parte oficial
la reunión con el primer ministro y
luego con el presidente que los recibió
con todos los honores en su palacio
presidencial asistió al primer encuentro
con la comunidad cristiana estaban ahí
todas las figuras de la iglesia en irak
presentes en esa catedral de nuestra
señora de la salvación que fue uno de
los lugares que ha vivido uno de esos
momentos más tristes de los cristianos
en la última década con un ataque de al
qaeda que dejó más de 50 muertos en
aquel momento allí se sentó el papá
francisco donde había muerto esta gente
mandando un mensaje a los terroristas de
que este país no se va a dejar vencer
por
sus actos ni tampoco ni las minorías
pero también más donde un mensaje para
la convivencia de todos en iraní dijo
que ese era el propósito uno de sus
propósitos de esta visita mañana viajará
a la ciudad de nayaf donde se encontrará
con el ayatolá alí sistaní la figura
religiosa más importante de este país en
otro acto cargado de simbolismo y
viajará al sur a una civil al lugar
donde estará el origen del profeta
abraham y que es uno de los lugares en
donde confluyen todas las religiones
pasamos ahora otras noticias la
organización mundial de la salud
calificó de muy seria y preocupante la
situación de la pandemia en brasil e
instó a las autoridades a tomar medidas
más agresivas el país se enfrenta a una
segunda ola agravada por la aparición de
nuevas variantes más peligrosa especial
esto el presidente de yair bolsonaro
mantiene su postura escéptica el informe
sede federico cuidar verena
el hobbit 19 avanza sin freno en brasil-
la presencia de nuevas variantes en los
sistemas sanitarios al borde del colapso
y la lenta vacunación conforman un
cóctel peligroso que elevó las alertas
en la organización mundial de la salud
de situaciones de visibles
la situación es muy seria y estamos muy
preocupados brasil debería tomar medidas
de salud pública agresivas mientras
sigue distribuyendo las vacunas agua en
olso rolling out vaccines este panorama
llevó a gobiernos como los de rio y sao
paulo a reinstaurar restricciones una
medida cuestionada por el presidente de
jair bolsonaro que el jueves instó a los
brasileños a dejar de llorar y quejarse
horas después bajo el tono pero repitió
las críticas a la política salvaje de
cerrar todo de nuevo no será buena
sabemos que el virus mata lamentamos las
muertes vamos a cuidar de las personas
el mandatario prometió la llegada de más
dosis de la vacuna para acelerar una
campaña que avanza de manera lenta e
irregular y sólo ha alcanzado al 35 por
ciento de la población
por eso la desesperación
y llevó a miles de adultos mayores a
hacer largas filas para conseguir la
inyección en esta ciudad del estado de
río de janeiro a pesar de que no cuenta
con dosis suficientes estoy aquí desde
las 4 de la mañana es absurdo un +10 y
hay personas que durmieron en la fila la
segunda hora se vio agravada en el país
por la presencia de variantes más
transmisibles y peligrosas que llevaron
las cifras de contagios y fallecimientos
a los peores niveles desde el inicio de
la pandemia según el equipo de respuesta
del gobierno brasileño el promedio de
los últimos 14 días es de 1250 decesos
por día y podría llegar hasta 3000 si no
se adoptan medidas serias para detener
la propagación del virus
renunció el ministro de salud de
paraguay en medio del colapso del
sistema hospitalario del país por la
pandemia de kobe 19 julio marx o lenin
estaba totalmente enfrentado con la
oposición en el senado que venía
reclamando su retirada del cargo las
críticas es un contra se acentuaron esta
semana con las denuncias de familiares
de pacientes y personal sanitario por la
falta de medicamentos e insumos en uno
de los hospitales más congestionadas por
los casos de kobe 19
'china estrechará aún más su control
sobre hong kong tras anunciar una
revisión sobre el sistema electoral de
la ciudad autónoma el congreso nacional
del pueblo fue el encargado de confirmar
que se creara un comité leal a beijing
que revisara y elegirá una gran parte de
la legislatura
la democracia en hong kong recibió un
nuevo golpe después de socavar durante
meses la autonomía de la ciudad y las
libertades de las personas
beijing ahora apunta directamente al
organismo legislativo del esclavo para
garantizar que sólo los diputados from
china ocupen sus asientos
en el caos en la sociedad de hong kong
muestra que existen lagunas y defectos
obvios en el sistema y mecanismo
electoral actual de la asamblea de
fondos
debemos asegurarnos de que los patriotas
constituyan el organismo principal que
administra hong kong el borrador de esta
propuesta otorga a un comité electoral
renovado nuevos poderes sobre el consejo
legislativo de hong kong conocido como
electo este comité sería capaz de
filtrar y elegir a la mayoría del
parlamento que ya impuso una nueva ley
el otoño pasado que permitió que los
legisladores anti patrióticos fueran
destituidos cuatro miembros de la
oposición fueron despedidos lo que
provocó que los diputados restantes
renunciarán en protesta los nuevos
cambios anularían cualquier intento de
los activistas prodemocracia de incluso
presentarse a elecciones
china generó una ola de condena
internacional el año pasado tras aprobar
una controvertida ley de seguridad para
hong kong diseñada para acabar con la
oposición la unión europea y eeuu
impusieron sanciones por la medida este
viernes la unión europea dio una nueva
advertencia para asegurar que puede
tomar medidas adicionales en respuesta
al último anuncio de beijing ya que
socava las libertades y el pluralismo
político en la ex colonia británica el
ex bailarín estrella de la ópera de
parís y de la danza patrick du pont
falleció este viernes esta fue la
trayectoria de quien hizo el baile su
vida marcando toda la historia de la
disciplina
patrick fue un astro en el firmamento de
la danza una estrella virtuosa de físico
felino y de una personalidad inflamable
su brillo inicio a los 10 años en la
escuela de la ópera de parís y solo le
bastaron otros 6 años para hacerse con
el más prestigioso concurso de danza del
mundo
se sentía un simple sirviente de su don
pero a los 21 en 1980 fue designado
habitual bailarín principal un título
que le llevó a trabajar con grandes
coreógrafos como móviles bella y a
bailar repertorios tanto clásicos como
contemporáneos
patrick tiene muchas posibilidades
muchos estilos diferentes y añadiría una
gran generosidad el consell diego city
en escena se entregaba por entero
generando gran complicidad con sus
compañeras 77 tan artista era alguien no
sólo ha nacido para ello con virtuosidad
técnica que era su caso sino porque
buscaba esa luz la busco desde joven
hacía lo que será el público cuando
bailaba don quijote y otros bailes más
contemporáneos
patrick tenía ganas de todo hiperactivo
como era llegó a ser director del ballet
de nancy antes de volver a la compañía
parisina de sus inicios además fue un
eterno viajero siendo toda una
celebridad en japón
víctima de un grave accidente de tráfico
luchó siempre por regresar a la danza
como en 2008 en esta comedia musical o
luego creando dos escuelas y siendo
jurado de un programa de televisión es
allí donde ofreció uno de sus últimos
bailes la última pirueta como estrella
apenas tenía 61 años pero su terrible
enfermedad no borrara su nombre de esta
gran disciplina
hasta que el informativo de france 24
continué con nosotros
[Música]